hold them accountable when they do
something wrong
teach them what it means to treat people
with empathy and respect teach them what
necessary forces teach them that deadly
force should be used rarely and only
when life is at risk
yes as with any profession there are
officers no question who aren't suited
for the job
some will cause trouble sometimes worse
we've seen that but in my experience
this is rare and becoming rare
well that's testimony on Capitol Hill
today meantime we have some breaking
news tonight Fox News has just confirmed
one of four fired Minneapolis police
officers charged in the death of George
Floyd has posted bail
Thomas Lane was released from jail this
afternoon after being locked up for
about a week
lane had been held in lieu of a $750,000
cash bail let's bring in our panel talk
about police reform what's happening
what's not
Charles Hurd opinion editor for The
Washington Times former Tennessee
congressman harold ford jr now currently
the chairman of our ex saver and matthew
kennedy founding editor of the
Washington free beacon Charlie this the
president says he's coming out with some
reforms list of reforms the testimony
today really dealt with a lot of
different factors is there some
bipartisan solution to this I think that
there certainly are obviously the dough
the devil is in the details but that
testimony from mr. Floyd's brother I
thought was remarkable it was very
powerful and it was a reminder that the
things that he talked about are things
that I think just about everybody
certainly every politician that has
talked about any of this stuff in
America today would agree with and when
he talked about the things that that
needed to be done such as better
training for police officers and
teaching and and you know reinforcing
the fact that deadly force must be rare
and only when life is at stake
that that's a far cry from some of the
crazier things
we're hearing some people talk about
about defunding police departments and
things like that I wish that I wish that
the peaceful protesters and the Democrat
Party everybody would just turn to mr.
Floyd's brother and listen to him
because because what he's talking about
right there has support from 99 percent
of Americans and is probably a very wise
way to go forward from here all right
here is the president today meeting in
the Cabinet Room with some
african-american leaders you go down a
list of criminal justice reform and and
all of the things we've done Opportunity
Zones the best unemployment rate in the
history just before the plague came in
and it's going to be back again soon but
you look at all of the things we've done
we've now worked on prison reform so
important and so many other things but
when you look at the economics when you
look at how well the black community has
been doing under this administration
nobody's done anything like we've done
there's a lot of questions about polls
nowadays and which ones are good and
which ones are bad the Gallup poll has
been cited by this president numerous
times when his approval was hide this
Gallup poll just out he takes a 10-point
hit from the beginning of May and
disapproval is up and then on party
identification down seven among
Republicans independents down seven
Democrats down nine but he's already
down at the bottom of the barrel there
Harold where do you see this now as far
as this president and what he does or
doesn't have to do to change his
situation Charlie laid out very well
what the country particularly Democrats
should do with mr. Floyd's brothers
testimony which I agree with Charlie was
all the things he said plus raw and
compelling all be very consistent with
the Floyd family's eulogy of their of
their brother and uncle and father I
would hope the president would listen as
well it's my understanding that some
members of senior members of the
president's staff including his
son-in-law was on the hill meeting with
Senator Scott and
President Trump was at the same time
touting that he's opposed to banning
chokeholds and limiting or lifting the
limited liability protections that
policemen or cops enjoy he should follow
mr. Floyd's brother's recommendations I
think we could find an easy and quick
and powerfully effective answer to the
challenges that a lot of Americans are
facing now with regard to that polling
and listening to what the president said
in that that ought that meeting with
some African American leaders it was
interesting COBIT unmasked and showed
the fragility that a lot of black
American households face particularly
working black holes black black
households face and the kinds of things
that we need to be thinking about the
kinds of investments we need to be
thinking about as a nation so as much as
the president is proud of the things
he's done and he should be kovat 19 has
revealed to us as a nation the kinds of
things that particularly African
Americans and brown and black
communities are facing including the
fact that black and brown house will
face a much much harsher reality from
kovat than other households and in these
poll the poll numbers I agree with you
Brett they are real at least at the
moment president could easily come back
but the most disturbing thing I saw on
your show tonight was that family in New
Jersey the brothers that decided to
react reenact some episode that they
believed happened in Minneapolis which
we all saw on tape is if that was some
way to say to the country this is the
right way to go and all the although the
president it's not responsible for what
they did
he does have some responsibility to
denounce it since they all were wearing
Trump t-shirts and Trump banners as they
re-enacted natural interlocking crises
the crises of the pandemic the crisis of
the economy and now the crisis of the
social unrest in the wake of the George
Floyd killing the public has turned
against among two of those three the
pandemic and the Floyd killing and so
it's very important for him I think to
recover the lost ground by encouraging
the bipartisan efforts of Senator Scott
to work out some type of police reform
bill
and Charlie quickly does he give a
speech on this moment as far as a race
speech oh I think he will and I think
he'll talk a lot about it between now
and the election and I think that he's
got a very strong position to stick up
for the police because the majority of
police are very good people they have
very very difficult jobs and the fact
that the the idea that you're going to
have anything you have an entire
political party up here
appearing to run off with this notion
that the police should police
departments should be burned down or
shut down or defunded or whatever that's
crazy
and if Donald Trump between now and the
election is running against that he's
going to have a very very strong hand